I will be paying tribute to her majesty
the queen personally but also on behalf
of Scotland and it will be an
opportunity for me but for the country
as a whole not just to pay tribute to
her majesty today but to convey our
condolences to the king and to The Wider
royal family today was is an opportunity
as it was yesterday for Scotland to
express how much the queen meant to us
Scotland was a place she loved deeply
and I think it has been very poignant to
see Scotland respond so appropriately to
her passing do you expect big clouds in
Edinburgh today and tomorrow again when
the the coffin was carried to the the
airport we had big roads in Edinburgh
and in many parts of Scotland yesterday
and that was lovely to see it was a sad
moment but nevertheless Scotland coming
together to express it's sorrow with the
passing of the queen was I think a
lovely moment to observe I would expect
because again today people will want to
continue to express their sorrow at the
Queen's death but this is also an
opportunity today for Scotland to convey
condolences directly to the king and the
royal family I would encourage people to
come along to be part of this occasion
but to as was the case yesterday to do
it safely and responsibly and be patient
and of course above all be respectful
and how important is the motion of
condolence in the Scottish Parliament
and what you and the other party leaders
have to say in the king's response
I think the Scottish Parliament motion
of condolence is an appropriate part of
this overall period of mourning for the
Queen the queen was a great friend of
the Scottish Parliament she has been
with us by our side at every key moment
in the still relatively Short history of
the institution she was there in 1999
when the parliament reconvenes she has
attended every official opening of the
parliament since then she gifted us the
mace that adorns our chamber today so
she has been a steadfast friend to the
Scottish Parliament so today is an
opportunity for MSP speaking I am sure
Pierce but also on behalf of the nation
to see how much she meant to us and when
she spoke at the opening last year in
October
Prince Charles as he was then was there
and it was almost as if she was passing
on the torch of the support for the
Scottish Parliament within the Royal
household
as he was King Charles as he is now has
been with her in the Scottish Parliament
on more than one occasion that was
certainly I think particularly prominent
in October last year but one of the
things that I think everyone has been
full of respect and admiration for is
that even as her health was very
obviously declining the queen was
determined to continue to fulfill all of
her duties because she had that deep
profound sense of public service and in
that I think she set an exceptional
example to all of us and you will have
your own audience with the new king this
afternoon what would you expect that to
be about
well as was the case with the queen
those conversations I am sure will
remain private and confidential and that
is something I will respect and but I'm
looking forward to having the
opportunity to speak with the the king
he has as his mother did a profound love
of Scotland and a very deep and detailed
knowledge of Scotland and I expect that
to be part of the conversations that we
have